[Music]
what's going on everybody Ian hardits
here on behalf of PFF welcome to BR
Fantasy Live awesome show for you guys
on the way but first off I want to talk
about a lot of quarterback news we have
dropping through this afternoon not one
not two three separate quarterback
changes have been announced starting off
with the Houston Texans Davis Mills has
been bench for Kyle Allen who I still
have not forgiven for making the world
think that Curtis salmon was not good at
football back in 2019 with the Panthers
so look I get it Davis Mills wasn't
helping this Texans team but you start
to look at the actual transactions they
have made over the past two three years
the decision to hire Lovie Smith who
hasn't had a winning season at any level
of football since when he coached the
Bears and you just start to wonder
exactly who could succeed in this
organization we'll see if Kyle Allen can
Zach Wilson has also been bench for Mike
White no not the creative White Lotus
but actually the Jets backup quarterback
who didn't exactly take the league by
storm last year but he did have that
cool 400 yard game come back Victory
against the Bengals look at a minimum
Mike White has shown the ability to put
up counting numbers even if the offense
still isn't great that's a lot more than
Zach Wilson pff's single lowest graded
passer on the season can attest to
having at this point also got a look at
the Carolina Panthers making yet another
move every single one of these
quarterbacks has suffered a high ankle
sprain at some point this season in the
original one Sam darnold finally healthy
enough to return so who will be taking
over Baker Mayfield serving as the
backup so just like Zach Wilson just
like Davis Mills awfully difficult to
you know look at Baker Mayfield and say
he's been anything other than terrible
this season that said Sam darnold maybe
could just come in and provide a slight
lift maybe just maybe coexist exist in
those two seconds between getting the
snap and throwing the ball in DJ Moore's
general direction so I actually am
cautiously optimistic about darnold
being back under Center not necessarily
this week against the Broncos Patrick
Cortana won the best pass defenses in
the NFL when they're not facing Devonte
Adams but here with DJ Moore and darnold
guys we we had a solid 12-game sample
last year of darnold managing to feed DJ
Moore an average of 9.8 targets per game
he averaged 70 yards and over five
catches per game in those appearances
and again 12 total starts so not the
smallest sample size in the world as bad
as DJ Moore has been this year the
previous years of his career was
actually a lot better because of folks
like Sam darnold Actually giving him a
chance to succeed but just so sad that
we are talking about TJ Moore actually
getting a bump up from Sam darnold if
you want to call him or Terry McLaurin
this Generations Alan Robinson who was
his Generations Andre Johnson the baller
wide receiver that just cannot Escape
one terrible quarterback after another I
think you'd be spot on
two other injury notes luckily kylo
Murray does expect to play this week has
missed the last two with a hamstring
injury the Cardinals have been very good
honestly over the past two years about
not bringing him back until he is fully
healthy and ready to go it appears that
is the time so the Colt McCoy two-game
stretch is over Kyla Murray will be
under Center here for the Cardinals week
12 matchup against the Chargers so get
back to treating him as a QB one final
note is that Justin fields did give us
an update on his left shoulder basically
saying it's an AC joint injury so does
not get him out of the Woodworks he is
still considered day to day and you know
while I wouldn't be overly concerned
about the left shoulder injury in terms
of a normal quarterback he was just
going to sit back there and throw the
ball 30 40 times per game with Fields it
does come into play a little bit more
they have put more on his plate as a
rusher than any quarterback in the
league this year and he's responded
fantastically fifth in the NFL in
rushing not among quarterbacks among
everybody Justin Fields is so with this
AC dry an injury it sure sounds like an
issue that could potentially get
re-aggravated or God forbid get even
worse by taking a bunch of contacts so
at a minimum Justin Fields is going to
be out there this week against sauce
Gardner in that tough New York Jets
defense there's reason to believe that
he could have that rushing workload cut
back enough to the point that maybe
we're not looking at the same sort of
locked in top five fantasy quarterback
moving forward in Justin field so again
fantastic starting the season for fields
and really the Bears in general I mean
talk about a well done tank job I'm not
exactly sure if this was their plan or
not but to see them at three and eight
this season and still have Justin Fields
flashing great day to be great in
Chicago with that everyone welcome to BR
Fantasy Live presented by State Farm
awesome show on tap for you today we are
doing starts and sits Thanksgiving
Edition and breaking down all the week
12 actions so we'll definitely get into
the chat all throughout Today's Show as
usual and we'll end things with an
extended start sit session with all of
you guys guys but first you want to go
ahead and give five players I'm planning
on starting this week and sitting now
this is all relative I'm not going to
come to you with you know top five yeah
start saquon Barkley and Derek Henry I
hate when fantasy analysts do that so
I'm going to try to avoid being someone
that I hate and on the sit side of
things trying to go out there on a limp
just a little bit so again not every
single lineup you will want to start or
sit these guys but relative as I'll
explain I do think there's reason for
enthusiasm and concern based on the
player
with that everyone we're going to start
off with Jeff Wilson in our fun little
Thanksgiving Day feature is going to
have him sitting at the starters table
that's right we got a starter's table
and a kids table here I want to be our
fantasy and we got the turkey Goblin as
well so with Jeff Wilson the reason why
he is going to be sitting at the
starters table is pretty much simple
it's twofold one he is the clear-cut
starting running back for the Miami
Dolphins at this point did not take him
any time at all since getting traded
from the 49ers and with Jeff Wilson now
having 60 snap 17 carries and five
Targets in their last game before the
buy Raheem moster is now a distant
backup in this equation the other side
of things is this matchup against the
Houston Texans easily the League's worse
defensive season in terms of PPR points
per game allowed to the position and
guys like again dead last 30 second I
get it that's bad they've almost taken
it to a new level only in 10 games this
year they've allowed the overall rb1 or
overall rb2 on five separate occasions
so they're not just kidding given up big
performances they're giving up week
winning performances and that's exactly
what Jeff Wilson has a chance to do in
this one so fire up Jeff Wilson get him
over there at that starters table and
reap the fantasy points Rewards
appreciate the chat from Mayfield is
mixing playing this week we will find
out my friend injury reports get
released on Wednesdays for those Sunday
games if he's out though samaje piran is
going to immediately enter that top 20
conversation is piran as good as Joe
Mixon no but we saw last week he doesn't
need to be as good as mixing to catch
three touchdowns in a game I believe
he's still the all-time rushing record
leader in college football for a single
game that was so wild when Melvin Gordon
and piran broke lt's record in back to
back weeks what a time to be alive if
Joe Mixon is out go get Smosh a piran
off that waiver wire he will give you
some rb2 production this week
from adith Khan would you rather start
Dak or Fields this is one of those
things where I would probably lean a DAC
because we're not exactly sure if Fields
is going to be out there in time so if
it was Fields versus uh you know Kenny
uh Pickett not to throw Kenny Pickett
under the bus here if it was a big
difference of 15 20 spots then I would
maybe wait and go ahead and take the
chance but with Dak we have someone
three straight top 12 finishes and even
if the Cowboys don't need to keep their
foot on the gas as much as fantasy
managers would like to see thanks to
having that great defense I do think
it's close enough for fields and Dak
that unless you have a third really good
insurance policy I would take the top 12
option that we are positive is going to
play
back to our start sets guys
unfortunately gonna have to populate
this kid's table over here just a little
bit not one running back but two running
backs in the same team Rashad white and
Leonard fournette sorry guys go ahead
and grab a seat at that kids table
now look with Rashad white things are
looking up and things are looking up in
the future with Rashad light those kids
are pumped to get these running backs
over there but look he started before
the Buy in Munich that was good now it's
not the whole story though when you
actually look at this equation in Tampa
Bay we had fournette suffer a hip injury
in that game which seemed to all be
Signs Now pointing to Rashad white but
guys the problem with this he's already
been cleared to play as ESPN's Adam
schefter noted he is not going to be
missing any time out there so we're shop
white and Leonard fournette hey it's
going to be probably a 50 50 split and
when the head coach top Bulls tells us
that they're going to be riding with the
hot hand here moving forward that's just
not what we want to hear in fancy land
so one of one of them Leonard fournette
or Rashad white my goodness we'd be
ranking them as a top 12 top 15 back
this week without hesitation because the
offense we've seen Tom Brady more than
enough check Downs to go around to
enable a fantasy friendly back but when
things are going to be split and
potentially made into a three-way
committee if a returning Giovanni
Bernard from IR has anything to say
about it I do think it's a situation
where you're keeping your shop like
you're keeping letter fournette you're
happy to have them on your roster you
shouldn't be happy about starting them
this week so it's also a situation where
it's not really four net and white it's
not Zeke and Pollard type like okay I
get it Rashad white I've watched the
games I agree he looks more explosive
from the eye test but for the season
he's averaging 3.7 yards per carry
Leonard fournette is at 3.4 fournette
has actually been the more efficient
receiver in terms of yards per out runs
so while I do think white has higher
upside down the stretch and has a chance
to take over fully it's not going to be
this week so sorry Rashad sorry Lenny
pull up that seat at the Kids Table
from Dre Rob uh do I consider sitting
pierced because of Houston chasing
points so not especially man look last
week was tough I mean he only had
negative two rushing yards before
contact on those 10 carries so tough to
expect him to make too much out of that
but one of the few things I would say
probably the only good thing that Lobby
Smith has done with this Houston Texas
team since arriving is get Damien pierce
his touch is more weeks than not so
again we have a low floor for any
running back in this sort of offense
where we know they can't flirt with
these you know sub 10 point outcomes
from time to time but maybe just maybe
Kyle Allen gives them a spark I don't
think he will but at the end of the day
peers should see 20 touches more weeks
than not and it's awfully tough to sit
someone like that on the bench
from poly cannoli do I like Montgomery
this week absolutely and I will be
saying with Dave Montgomery guys when
you start looking at his potential now
in this backfield I think there's a good
case to be made that he should even be
sitting at the starters table
there's that turkey gobble with Dave
Montgomery look guys it's pretty simple
it's a volume game at the end of the day
is what we're trying to do in fantasy
we're much better at predicting who's
gonna get the touches and who's gonna do
what with those opportunities and what
Khalil Herbert on IR with the hip injury
it's now a situation in Chicago where
there's only one running back remaining
now Justin Abner is going to get a few
touches here or there but with
Montgomery a player that they have
proven willing to use on across all
three Downs throughout his entire time
in Chicago and including this year now
without Herbert it's just another
situation where we could be looking at
20 plus weekly touches very similar
reasoning when we talked last week about
you know certain trades to make and why
I wanted everyone to try to get James
Connor on the squad what do you think
Dave Montgomery is truly a great NFL
running back or not really it doesn't
matter because the Bears do and they've
proven willing to give this dude 20 plus
touches more weeks and not so David
Montgomery overall 79 snap 17 carries
and four targets last week and look I
think it almost gets underrated how
actually good he can be breaking tackles
the numbers he put up at Iowa State have
continued into the NFL and even though
he can't put his foot in the ground and
break off 80-yard touchdown runs like
Prime saquon Barkley guess what not many
guys in the NFL can so Montgomery has
always had a three down skill set he's
slippery out there I mean my God if you
guys watched that game last week
literally the first play of the game
Montgomery caught a pass in the fly and
turned what should have been no yards
into a good nine after breaking three
tackles out there so it's not the
easiest matchup against the Jets this
week but volume is volume at Montgomery
has a ton of it
from Thrasher is it weird that I want to
sit Patterson this week it is because as
the longtime reigning president of the
Cordero Patterson fan club the man is a
king and now the sole owner of the
number one spot of most kick return
touchdowns in NFL history but what we
just talk about that's sweet sweet
volume and unfortunately Arthur Smith is
not giving CPAP the sort of volume that
has fantasy managers would love to see
so again this pains me Cordero Patterson
is literally my favorite player in the
NFL
go ahead and get a seat at the Kids
Table Cordero I'm sorry man
foreign
kids are happy they should be Cordero
seems like one of the coolest guys out
there but again guys comes down to the
volume and since returning from injury
he's had 14 6 and 12 touches again best
kick returner in NFL history kicks I
didn't say punts chill out Devin Hester
stands and Bears fans out there and at
the end of the day you guys have seen
you know Kyle Pitts and Drake London not
be able to produce in this passing game
that's because nobody is this is the
most run heavy offense in the league so
we have corduro Patterson out there not
getting all the rush attempts Tyler
algier actually played more snaps in him
last week and continues to be heavily
involved but also giving us almost a
near weekly zero in the passing game so
the talent is there with Cordero
Patterson we've seen he's healthy he had
two touchdowns in his first game back
from injury but guys we're just not
getting enough consistent volume from
Arthur Smith and a Falcons offense that
unfortunately we can't expect to be
scoring uh you know upwards of 30 points
more weeks than not so really with
Patterson it's more so an issue of his
environment and even in this specific
matchup too it's not ideal the
Washington commanders have allowed the
fourth Buist PPR points for game two
opposing running backs so Cordero again
is all relative guys I haven't ranked as
my rb27 this week there's a good chance
that that's warrants a flex spot in your
starting lineup but again in terms of
someone who you should be going out
there starting no matter what even if
there's a fire again it pains me but
Cordero Patterson should probably be sat
in more lineups not this week until if
ever we are confident again that he has
even a 15 to 20 touch ceiling
unfortunately Arthur Smith gonna Arthur
Smith with this situation as well from
Vic the truth is Logan Thomas back to
his old self so
I don't think so in terms of just how he
of how I think he's looked out there on
the field coming back from such a major
injury that happened late in the season
being you know 30 years of age and all
that is to be expected but his workload
is back to being his old self ran around
over 80 percent of the snaps uh last
week and kind of lost in the JD
mckissick IR news was the fact that
Armani Rogers won their other backup
tight ends was also placed on the IR so
Logan Thomas look it's an offense with
McLaurin Curtis Samuel Jahan Dotson
Antonio Gibson it's not a guarantee that
Logan Thomas is going to be getting five
six targets during every single week he
could be the number five pass game
option more weeks not moving forward
that said full-time role in the offense
a new tight end seemingly gets hurt
every single week that we can no longer
use in fantasy land I do think that we
can go ahead and start trusting Thomas a
little bit more as a top 15 option at
the position
from Brandon Guerra Swift or rashab
white or neither I would get the slight
lean towards Rashad white because the
thing with DeAndre Swift guys that we're
gonna have to have a tough conversation
about it's that volume I love DeAndre
Swift You Love DeAndre Swift right now
apparently Dan Campbell and the Lions do
not love DeAndre Swift so again we draft
them in round one back in August and it
pains me to be doing this right now but
go ahead and pull up a sit at the Kids
Table go ahead and pull up a seat at the
Kids Table DeAndre Swift
it is so sad that we have to do this
with swift but you know what guys it's a
reality of the situation at this point
32 snaps five carries and three targets
last week guys he's not getting the run
at this point Justin Jackson is
unironically playing ahead of an
allegedly healthy DeAndre Swift now if
this was a situation where we could
clearly tell when the Lions were ready
to ramp things up when it was going to
be time to get back to giving him the
same sort of workload that we saw early
on in the season that'd be great I'd be
back in trying to guess the week every
single time that Swift is going to get
that usage ramp back up it is not a
guarantee though because he continues to
practice in full the end of the week and
he's not even being given an injury
designation so coming back off the buy
he was not listed as questionable and
he's playing limited snaps the next week
he was questionable last week he wasn't
again so no Rhyme or Reason to the
injury report and how the lines are
actually going out there and treating
them right now so Jamal Williams a
Monroe Saint Brown the only shirt things
in this Lions offense at the moment we
can't even have faith that DeAndre Swift
is going to get 10 combined carries and
targets out there why can't the Lions
feed a guy averaging 6.1 yards per carry
even 10 carries per game I don't know
but unfortunately again it's the reality
of the situation in Detroit right now so
Jamal Williams and that is going to be
it from this Lions backfield at the
moment
all right guys also want to be talking
about Aaron Rodgers here now Aaron
Rodgers hasn't exactly been given us the
best starts throughout the year but once
you start looking at the quarterback
rankings you can start to make a case
for a guy like him after the first eight
or nine players that said once we start
looking at the matchup for this week I
am sorry Aaron Rodgers you got to take a
seat at that kid's table brother
with this one guys again a lot of it
comes down to that matchup against the
Eagles I mean this secondary you can say
what you want about the run defense
without Jordan Davis in there number two
in EPA allowed per pass play number one
in yards per attempt allowed number one
in passer rating out loud so big group
effort Darius Slay James bradberry's
been someone won the best off-season
signings I mean look you look you guys
have seen the moves the Eagles make even
when Jordan Davis gets hurt and they
have a week or two of problems seemingly
in their interior defensive line they go
find a way to get limp all Joseph and
the Dominican Sue involved so all levels
of this defense they've just been
phenomenal and as much as I would like
to think Rogers and Jalen hurts could
have a Sunday night shootout for us all
to enjoy I'm just not confident enough
in this passing game being good as we've
seen you know to varying degrees of
issues throughout the season and also
having that volume if you go back and
look at honestly the best offense
performance from the Packers this year
in that Cowboys game just two weeks ago
the big problem that we did see come
from that was Roger selling through the
ball 20 times now Christian Watson
happened to catch three of those four
touchdowns that was great to see but
can't be relying on such a high
touchdown rate moving forward Aaron
Rodgers unfortunately someone that we're
gonna have to sit just at this point in
his career no rushing up sign that
matchup I do not want to mess around
with it
have another guy to go over that's been
a little bit controversial throughout
this year but I do think we could see
some better days ahead that's going to
be Tyler Higby pull up a seat at the
starters table my man it does seem like
now we can finally get back behind him
as a top 10 times
a couple weeks ago I did come to you
guys on this and say that I didn't
believe Higby was going to keep on
keeping on as a top 10 tight end because
we had actually seen a decent amount of
evidence that they were using them more
as a blocker which makes sense pff's
32nd ranked offensive line Matthew
Stafford Bryce Perkins John Wolford
whoever's been on set under Center very
little time to throw all season long so
the only problem here guys is when we
actually start to look at the evolution
of the role once Cooper cup got
sidelined the Rams basically balked on
their idea of using Higby Moore as a
blocker and they've just gone back to
feeding him the ball in the past game 89
route rate last week and you start
looking at this offense Alan Robinson
still hasn't had a game with more than
65 receiving yards van Jefferson took
him to his third game of the season to
actually make a catch I mean Kyron
Williams or Cam makers maybe a running
back steps up at some point But
ultimately the only shirt thing and the
sad excuse for an offense is Tyler Higby
getting a bunch of targets so full PPR I
have Tyler taking me as my Titan six
this week I would still start guys like
Dalton Schultz TJ Hawkinson you know
Andrews Kittle and Kelsey obviously
ahead of him but that sweet sweet volume
is making Tyler Higby a far better
fantasy player than real life Talent
necessarily and hey guys style points
don't matter in fantasy we'll take all
the targets we can get
all right guys two more wide receivers
to break down now first of all if you
think this is common sense that is very
okay but I just want to make sure God
forbid there's one of you out there even
considering putting a Monroe Saint Brown
anywhere near that fantasy bench do not
do that a manra the Sun God himself go
go ahead and pull up a seat at that
starter's table
would have been good to get like you
know a sun god graphic of a Monroe is
that not just one of the best nicknames
that we've heard quite some time the guy
acts like it so guys last 13 non-injured
games we did have a lull this season but
that came from an ankle entry and then a
concussion suffered against the Cowboys
receptions in his last non-13 injured
games 10 8 8 9 8 8 9 6 7 4 10 and most
recently seven the guy's idea of a dud
is a four catch 55 Yard game he's the
wide receiver 10 expected PPR points per
game this season and the wide receiver
15 and real PPR points per game and
those are even skewed because he had the
game in week four I believe where he was
on limited snaps playing with the ankle
injury and then the Cowboys game where
he was unfortunately concussed before he
can get much of anything going so this
is a situation where the bills very good
defense but we have seen this banged up
secondary be had by more than a few wide
receivers over the year and when you
start to add it up that ranked as 24th
and and PPR points per game allowed to
opposing wide receivers so again maybe
we see a situation where Jamison
Williams is back before too long but I
don't hate the idea of adding a fuel
stretch or talent to this offense to
help clear out some of the underneath
intermediate areas of the field in the
meantime all the volume in the world
continuing to go to a Monroe in a game
that we're expected to see have all
sorts of fireworks highest game total of
the week between bills and lions in that
first Thanksgiving Day matchup on Monroe
Saint Brown don't even think about
putting him near your fantasy bench this
Thanksgiving
also got to give some love over too a
certain New England Patriots slot
receiver guys Jacoby Myers keeps on
keeping on it might not be you know the
most stylistic most aesthetically
pleasing performances out there I get it
he's not the biggest dude but again
fantasy points are fantasy points
Jacoby's been scoring a lot of them and
for that Jacoby Myers go ahead and pull
up a seat at the starters table
hey Vikings bottom six defense and PPR
points per game allows through the
position and it's one of those things
where I don't blame you guys if you
haven't caught a lot of Patriots games
this season I mean that offense other
than ramondre Stevenson really has been
tough to watch more weeks than not but
Jacoby Myers when you start adding up
all these short receptions even a couple
touchdowns that he's managed to score
this year the wide receiver 20 in PPR
points per game tied with a little
someone named Michael Pittman so again
who do I think is better in real life
Pittman or Jacoby absolutely Michael
Pittman good thing we're not playing
real life football we are stuck in this
Fantasy game and with that Jacoby
getting force fed with Mac Jones under
Center his Targets in the last 11 games
with Mac six six 13 twice six nine eight
eight eight twelve and eight so that's
basically a long way of saying the
dude's averaging almost nine targets per
game with Mac Jones and Her full PPR
it's tough to keep anyone with that sort
of workload anywhere near that fantasy
bench so loved your Kobe Myers go go
ahead get that see you at the starters
here able getting crowded but he
certainly deserves that spot but it is
crowded and with that we need to go
ahead and send our last player we're
talking about today back over to the
kids table unfortunately guys you know
we're not going to have all the Chiefs
wide receivers there but the only cheese
wide receiver I care about this week and
really probably moving forward is going
to be Juju Smith Schuster and for that
Marquez Valdez scantling sorry bro I
don't care how many injuries there are
gonna have to pull up a seat at that
kid's table so I get it it is Patrick
Mahomes in this Chiefs offense they can
do great things it's scary putting any
of these guys
there we go kids bring on mvs it's scary
putting any of these guys in the bench
because we see examples of Sky Moore
randomly breaking out to like a 65-yard
extent on Sunday Night Football cadera's
Tony gets all the hype in the world so
when you start removing some pieces you
get it in your head that okay now the
complimentary guys will step up and have
these bigger roles but man there's been
opportunity for mvs all season long and
it just hasn't gotten there he's been
starting alongside Juju ever since week
one but yet five or fewer targets and
five consecutive games who the other
wide receivers Justin Watson got to
start last week only four targets I
understand that Sky Moore did have a
good game out there but he didn't even
play a full-time role because the chiefs
were more willing to use two tight end
sets than leaning on 11 personnel like
they do and everyone's healthy so there
is Tony out with the hamstring injury he
was not able to practice on Wednesday
Miko Hartman still on the injured
reserve list and he's going to miss at
least the next three games as well so
really it's Juju Smith Schuster and is
everyone else in Kansas City at the wide
receiver room obviously Travis Kelsey
going to be eating just fine from the
tight end position but then we look at
the match-up not the easiest in the
world against Aaron Donald and Jalen
Ramsey and Company and to see the Chiefs
as 14 and a half Point favorites I'm not
so sure they'll need to keep their foot
on the gas as much as usual so non Juju
Chief wide receivers go ahead and get
over that kids table and we will see you
maybe next week but with that guys we
are going to jump into personalized
fantasy advice presented by State Farm
with a personal price plan is all about
creating a price just for you get those
start sick questions go in chat I am
here and I'm just here to help I just go
win some go win some fantasy games on
Thanksgiving is there anything better
than just eating good food and winning
Fantasy matchups I don't think so
from at mandeli Jamal Williams or Devon
Singletary I'm actually gonna lean
towards Devin Singletary just slightly
here even after they've added Naim Heinz
four straight games with over 70 snap
rate and as much as Jamal Williams does
have a big time chance to you know score
touchdowns diving from the goal line we
saw it three times uh last week
Singletary also has three touchdowns
over the past two games bills are
implied to score a week high 32 points I
think the touches are similar and at
that point give me the bills offense
over the lions from at hoof hearted ooh
love that Brewery do we play saquon or
Travis etn well this is like the
Muhammad McLovin thing why is it between
saquon and Travis etn start both of them
man it's gonna be say cuando in that
situation but truly these are two of my
top eight running backs on the week stop
playing in four man fantasy football
leagues please from at kpat 12 sleepers
to pick up for the playoffs appreciate
you guys coming here on the BR Fantasy
Live asking the tough hard hitting
questions so again I'm gonna I'm gonna
repeat a couple names I think I actually
told you last week low owned handcuffs
is some of the most fantasy friendly
running backs in a Fantasy Football
starting off as samaje piran for the
Bengals now we're already seeing this
come to fruition where we actually have
Joe Mixon in the concussion protocol
whether he's able to suit up Sunday
remains to be seen but there are a
couple more out there
Derrick Henry currently leading the NFL
in rushing yards per game it's all
awesome until it's not God forbid Derek
Henry misses any time don't show her
could see that role expand in a hurry
yes we would still have some Hassan
Haskins out there but I do think
Hilliard in a Tennessee offense without
too many other places to go with the
ball could emerge as a bit of a you know
middle class low man uh Poor Man's
Austin Eckler of sorts in Tennessee and
the final one is going to be saquon
Barkley speaking of his backup Matt
Brita again not someone that we just
crossed out saquon's name and put Matt
Brita in there you know if he happened
to get injured or something like that
but when you start looking at the low
low percentage of rosters he's even
owned on ESPN Yahoo and whatever site
you happen to use you can just see that
there is a lot of upside and he's the
sort of player that could be one injury
away from being on the cover of all
those wafer wire articles so Matt breida
doncho Hilliard and also samaja piran my
final note would be Tyler Conklin who we
talked about last week looking ahead to
the top Fantasy Playoff schedules guys
Mike White now in for Zach Wilson one of
only two quarterbacks the check down
rate above 10 percent over the past two
seasons the other one is Joe Flacco so
when you move away from Zach Wilson is
far more aggressive Michael Carter and
Tyler Conklin especially I do think
should see a lot more volume so Conklin
easiest schedule of any tight end in
weeks 15 through 17 in the fantasy
playoffs in terms of the fantasy points
for game Allowed by the opponents I
think Conklin could be a big time
producer down the stretch of Mike White
or Joe Flacco under Center but yes chat
love these Starship questions keep them
coming anything else that is on your
mind of course welcome as well
from Advent Champion 101 alave or t
Higgins very good problem to have
clearly he got a good squad out there
got to give the slight nod though to T
Higgins as great as the olave game was
last week since Jarvis Landry has gotten
back there they have been more and more
willing to keep some of the other guys
involved and I don't love hearing about
how the Saints are you know all in now
and apparently trying to re-embrace this
taysom hill package so honestly guys
another potential sleeper down the
stretch still only owned about 37
percent of ESPN leagues is taysom Hills
so it does seem more and more likely
that the Saints are more or less done
with the Jameis Winston experience and
as weird as it is that tastem Hill has
this tie-down eligibility if we do see a
situation down the stretch where taysom
gets to start games as a quarterback and
we get to play them at tight end in
fantasy that's going to be a borderline
cheat code and you're gonna be a lot
happier that you had him on your roster
in the meantime
from at ashy boy Kittle or Schultz gotta
get the slight knot to George Kittle I
do think Schultz has been on the open up
with Dak Prescott under Center almost
had a touchdown last week just went out
with one hand instead of two got a nice
tweet from Dez Bryant even criticizing
him for uh that decision but to me every
single week pretty much Kelsey Andrews
Kittle and A Tear of their own at the
top Schultz the quality top five Titan
just not in my top three from at
Hollywood is Gino a certified stutter
now yeah Manny he really has been
throughout the season you know I don't
know how many times mainstream media
needs to see the guy have great games
before they say he's a great quarterback
so having Metcalf Lockett a great run
game in Kenneth Walker this whole
Seattle offense has been awfully good
this year and that's why before thereby
they were a top five ranked scoring
offense so Gino Smith no I don't think
he's like a consistent guy you're going
to be asking me like Justin Herbert
versus Geno Smith questions for but in
terms of being in that tier with guys
like Tom Brady like Dak Prescott your
low end qb1 group Geno Smith belongs
from App B Payne Higgins Christian
Watson or Palmer sit too I am going to
be taking T Higgins do you guys just see
the game that t Higgins had last week
absolute madness out there and yes we
could see Jamar Chase come back but Joe
burrow in this Bengals offense are
clicking in a major way right now so 10
total offensive touchdowns scored over
the last two weeks look piran and mix
and I've combined for eight that's
awesome I don't think the running backs
are going to keep having such a high
touchdown share in this offense moving
forward T Higgins again continue to jam
him in Far More starting lineups than
not guys I still got another five
minutes let's keep these chat questions
flying great day to be great as always
here on BR Fantasy Live at Jonathan sir
Myers Judy or Lazard yeah man I'm going
with Kobe Myers again got that seat at
the starters table for a reason I know
lizard actually did have a pretty solid
Target share last week but moving more
and more towards Christian Watson and
yeah give me the guy that I am expecting
to see eight to nine targets and he just
continuously gets the good matchups from
the friendly confines at the slot so
Vikings secondary I mean you guys saw
that Cowboys game not exactly the group
to be you know the most fearful about
the moment so Jacoby Myers volume
induced borderline wide receiver 2 for
me
at Alec goal is Odell worth grabbing
right now and especially deeper leagues
yeah that's fine but let's just think a
little bit about the two popular spots
they're talking about the Giants and it
seems more inevitable like the Cowboys I
mean are we hyped up about playing
Michael Gallup these days we are not and
that is because of how good Micah
Parsons and his defense are and how
willing the Cowboys are to actually go
out there and run the football six most
run heavy team in the NFL this year in
terms of pass player rate and
non-garbage time situations so one of
those things where O'Dell was awesome on
the Rams last year we saw those
touchdowns you know the playoff run was
great but he still wasn't someone that
was more than the wide receiver for
three more weeks than not so guess what
there's not that many wide receiver
three type talents on the waiver wire so
from that perspective yes but I don't
think regardless of where Odell signs
he's going to be like a must start asset
down the stretch if he is truly fully
healthy and ready to go after
Thanksgiving
at geraldj need a tight end who I can
pick up from waivers you came to the
right spot my friend looking at my tight
end rankings which you can find over at
pff.com so I have Dave nijoku as my
Titan aide if he is still out there
definitely grab him particularly with
the Sean Watson's you know suspension up
before too long people might have
dropped him while he was injured after
najoku Greg Dolce Cole commit and Juwan
Johnson this would probably be the guy
that you're going to be able to get in a
lot of leagues not taysom Hill the other
Saints tight end five touchdowns in his
last five games and he's been a top ten
scoring tight end this season so Juwan
Johnson if you do need a tight end and
pick off of waivers I do think he is
your guy
at Jack Daniels 13 Pollard or Taylor
this is another one of those questions
you guys are coming to me with the most
loaded teams I've ever freaking seen so
yes I'm gonna take Jonathan Taylor but I
ranked Tony pauler as my rb8 this week
so look Jack this one's on you man
you're picking between Tony pauler and
Jonathan Taylor I don't want to be the
bad guy when I picked the one that
scores three fewer points top eight
running backs be a man go pick the one
that you feel best about it's two great
choices to have from at ACD AJ brown or
Scary Terry it is getting closer and
closer between these two McClure and
eighth in the NFL and receiving yards
the problem is as we've seen Washington
offense not really scoring as many
points as the Eagles so hey two guys I
have ranked inside my top 12 but I do
have ajb ahead just by a few spots from
at Bay native warrior Sutton or Curtis
Samuel if we see Jerry Judy and KJ
Handler missed this week again I do
think it's going to continue to be
Courtland Sutton so Curtis Samuel
basically just suffering from the same
kind of things that I've heard Colin sun
it's a low scoring offense with a lot of
mouths to feed in the passing game and
with Sutton you take away some of the
other Mouse to feed and we can feel
better about the volume so Curtis Samuel
still getting his On The Run game board
and anything but we'll take sudden in
the potential for eight to ten targets
about five more guys at mikeyrod210 at
uh dpj Palmer or George Pickens in the
flex I'm gonna lean towards Josh Palmer
here assuming Mike Williams is going to
be out of the picture and also Joe
whatever potentially that was kind of
the low-key I think reason why we saw
Palmer and Keenan Allen so heavily
featured last week while he did get
Keenan Allen back Justin Herbert just
can never I guess have his full
assortment of weapons healthy for more
than 10 minutes at a time which is
unfortunate for him but good for someone
like Josh Palmer who should continue to
see far more volume than dpj and Pickens
despite both those players obviously
doing really great things over the past
couple of weeks
from at Nunu 14 Kamara or a manra in the
flex oh you put me on the spot full PPR
I would have to go a Monroe they haven't
been throwing the ball to Kamara nearly
as much in recent weeks when Dalton came
under Center I want to say he had four
straight games with at least six
receptions but over his past three games
total only 10 combined receptions for
Alvin Kamara so it's one of those
situations where he's unfortunately just
a rocking a hard place at times because
he's not getting thrown the ball as much
in the passing game especially now with
Jarvis in a lave doing their things and
then when you get inside the 10 yard
line always a chance for professional
vulture taysom Hill to get in there and
take matters into his own hands so once
again Kamara versus freaking of manra
Saint Brown These are players that in 99
of lineups I think you'd have no problem
starting both but if you're gonna put me
on the spot give me the sun god
from at Nick Gibson 23 Jacob's Elliott
or Pollard sit one yeah I'm sitting Zeke
Man Tony Pollard is getting more Touches
at this point he's the more explosive
player Josh Jacobson pace for 2007 yards
this year take a seat Zeke from at the
real Seb Connor Pollard Aaron Jones
start two I would have to just barely
sit Aaron Jones in this one really tough
matchup against the Eagles on Sunday
Night Football Pollard's in the better
offense and honestly with a better role
at this point James Connor the only
running back in Arizona and the fact
we're getting kylo Murray back seemingly
getting him back he said today that he
expects to play should mean only good
things for the scoring upside of Conor
and everyone else involved and one
low-key interesting thing about turtles
Kyler Murray doesn't QB sneak he only
has one time in his entire career and
we've actually seen Colt McCoy And even
Chris streveler who is their other
quarterback to get his spot start over
the years they have been used in that
capacity so when they get inside that
five yard line guys the ball is going
the James Connor from at trooper123 in a
joku or Everett probably Dave in the
joker I'm not even sure if Everett's
going to be out there playing he did
suffer that groin injury so I'm go ahead
and go in joku for now and finally at s
Powers 366 locket or Goblin this one is
so close it's been close all season full
PPR I'm taking Chris gaultman since he
returned in week four only Tyreek Hill
has more freaking targets so it hasn't
really been a problem in terms of
workload for Goblin this year he just
hasn't been able to find the end zone
until he finally did in Germany so still
zero touchdowns on American soil I do
think about plenty of chances to turn
that around against the Browns defense
31st in scoring and 31st in the EPA
allowed per play so both top 20
receivers if you do think personally a
lock it's better look I haven't ranked
within three spots of each other so
nothing egregious but give me Chris
Goblin I think it's a great matchup and
he should have more guaranteed volume
and with that everybody we're gonna wrap
things up thank you for tuning in to
another edition of BR Fantasy Live
presented by State Farm
enjoy Thanksgiving best holiday of the
year in my humble opinion and yeah eat
food watch football have a couple drinks
do whatever makes you happy it's a great
time to be thankful so thanks again for
tuning in everybody I'm Ian Hardison
until next time take care
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]